bienvenue sur diagonale tu es toujours
championnat du monde kramnik topalov
avec les walis en fait un scandale
énorme qui t'a rien dans ce championnat
une surprise incroyable stéphane puisque
c'est historique ça n'arrive jamais
c'est quelque chose d'exceptionnel
il y a eu une partie qui a été perdu par
forfait alors par forfait alors disons
qu'on va on va voir ça tout de suite
on va voir ça toute la partie numéro 5
qu'on est sensé commenter aujourd'hui
et bien cette partie numéro 5
voilà si on peut l'avoir voilà terminé 0
1 en 0 coup oui c'est une surprise donc
surprenante et comme toute surprise 010
coup en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est
que vladimir thermique est arrivé et
plainte de topalov qui avait été déposé
en fin plateau alors personnellement
l'équipe topalov emmené par silvio
danilov dont on va reparler bien entendu
une plainte a été déposée sur le fait
que chronique avec trop souvent aux
toilettes
donc d'où doute sur le fait que
chroniques soient aidés par un
ordinateur possibilité de triche de
complot et ainsi de suite
l'équipe d'annie l'offre a fait une
demande et on a donc fermé à clé les
toilettes de vladimir kramnik mais
kravica protesté implique évidemment
arrive dans son temps demain il va aux
toilettes alors la porte est fermée
on a total of a menacé quand même de
faire forfait c'est à dire qu'il a fait
plainte donc
la fée plainte le jeudi il fait plein de
bleus jeudi et il dit voilà je ne trouve
pas normal enfin l'équipe on ne trouve
pas normal que topal if taupe à l'oeuf
le top alif kramnik comme 9 octobre à
lille que krainik puisse à faire dans le
temps d'aller vue aux toilettes etc
si le match continue ces conditions nous
nous considérons le forfait ski et un ce
qui est tout à fait un croix puisque
kramnik à ce moment là donc mène 2 0 et
donc peu pâlot fait un peu la tête sous
l'eau et il menace de faire forcer ce
qui ne fait pas crédible le jura la mise
quand on mène au score menacé de faire
forfait ça peut être crédit mais quand
on est mené surtout 2-0 en plus menacé
de faire un forfait c'est perdre toute
crédibilité quand je pense à tous
niveaux
c'est une démarche assez surprenante
m'enfin si topalov se sont vraiment
lésés par le fait que de parler de
possibilités que la dynamique soit aidé
cette demande devient légitime entre
guillemets évidemment puisque
l'honnêteté de la demande quand même
assez douteuses alors il ya eu suite
suite à cette cette demande il ya eu une
commission d'appel qui dirigé par
notamment le bien nommé makropoulos le
plus honnête qui soit sur la planète
échec très certainement une makropoulos
avec est un grand maître d'échecs qui
est internationalement et dès qu'on m'a
dit les grands maîtres
un autre makropoulos et effectivement il
est au sein de la fédé depuis un bout de
temps déjà
il est connu pour être effectivement des
noirs à la c2 il est en fait un peu le
directeur de l'afi des illuminati nommé
fait un président est bien que dans le
chairman de la passade sherman je crois
donc celui un peu qui a en charge de
l'exécutif finalement et oui donc il
préside en plus la commission d'appel
donc ce qui pose un problème d'ailleurs
stéphane escaffre le président de la
des arbitres en france en fait la
direction de l'arbitrage justement a
souligné que c'est quand même pas normal
que l'exécutif soit en même temps chargé
du judiciaire il ya vraiment un souci à
ce niveau-là et ce qui s'est passé c'est
que en plus donc là la plaine de topalov
de toute façon en plus ce n'était pas
fait dans les temps c'est à dire que
l'allemagne doit être fait deux heures
après la fin d'une partie tout plein de
doit être fait deux heures pourrait
faire une partie ensuite donc déjà ça
s'est fait au lendemain ça ça fait le
jeudi
donc s'il ya un souci de ce côté là donc
rami qui a posé toutes les réserves et
se réserve le droit aussi d'attaquer la
fidh en justice après le match et
topalov donc menace de faire de faire
forfait à ce moment là la commission
d'appel accepte sa requête et ferme les
toilettes quand tu vas à signaler cette
fois c'est kramnik donc qui vient qui
lui a tant que ces toilettes sont
ouvertes puisque bon mais il justifie
ses elle est venue parce qu'il a besoin
de bouger puis de toute façon il
apparaît quand il dit qu'on n'a pas
revenir sur un point du contrat qui a
été signé au départ donc c'était un
point qui était clair et net est
d'autant plus que dissimuler que tout
changement des conditions de jeu devait
faire avoir l'accord des deux joueurs
donc il ya ce problème là et en plus que
la croquette de biotope allofs et hors
délai et la commission d'appel donne
raison à topalov sens mais n'entendre
kramnik fermé toilettes et derrière dans
chronique pour sa partie donc attend que
les toilettes sont ouvertes c'est ça
nous rappelons effectivement que dans un
champion du monde dont il ya deux
joueurs qui jouent sur une scène et
effectivement les joueurs d'échecs
il ya beaucoup de tensions ont
l'habitude ont pour habitude les deux
joueurs de champagne pour habitude
d'aller dans leur loge donc se reposer
ou il ya effectivement des toilettes une
sorte de salle de bain un petit espace
des chocolats des choses comme ça où ils
sont détendus et décontractés tout seul
donc effectivement tout ça est prévu
dans la nommant on décide
d'amputer la chronique de moitié de sa
loge quand avec la motié toilettes c'est
un film n'a pas été acceptée par
vladimir kramnik ce qui est tout à fait
compréhensible
moi je comprends si l'une puis bon il ya
donc des normes d'énormes fautes de même
de fonctionnement qui ont été faites
we are coming out stéphane comme peu le
problème principal qui arrive qui est
nouveau dans les bancs les échecs c'est
le sait la présence des ordinateurs
c'est la même série qui pourrait de ce
fait relaté sibilité se faire aider par
un ordinateur pendant la partie par les
parties dans le droit évidemment mais
des compétences internes mais ça change
tout parce qu'il ya dix ans les
ordinateurs n'étaient pas du tout au
niveau
donc on pouvait se faire aider mais
c'était une aide qui reste est humaine
ouais et qui restait donc d'ici à l'été
pour moi l'avenir que en général même
une équipe de joueurs a du mal à aller
aussi vite qu'un champion du monde en
pleine réflexion tous à la médiation
alors que la ville ordinateur c'est
plutôt la vistoire l'ordinateur va être
très vite que trouver des choses très
rapide dans certains types d'oppositions
il est bien plus fort que le champion du
monde lui-même
donc effectivement maintenant il ya un
authentique risque que le match puisse
être il m'a lancé ce qui est incroyable
c'est que ces topalov qui qui fait 7 7 7
cette action enfin je dirais ce doute
qui met ce doute ce kramnik or c'est
lui-même qui est le joueur du circuit le
plus susceptible le plus suspects et
d'utiliser des ordinateurs il paraît
même que son surnom dans le circuit
c'est faux nitot ses fournisseurs comme
quoi il
une oreillette et d'ailleurs monrose
évite ch qui a qui a dans le classement
mondial des meilleurs joueurs de la
planète qui a mis je crois le logis le
logiciel russe je sais plus lequel les
guideront il s'appelle ce logiciel
russie d'amis en premier et il a mis en
deuxième joueur mondial dan hay l'ofs le
manager de ghettos pas lorsque ce qui
laissait sous-entendre voilà bon alors
après qu'est-ce qui est vrai qu est-ce
qui est pas vrai en fait c'est encore
plus paradoxal de remarquer que topalov
qui lui même est suspecté d'utiliser un
ordinateur ce soit lui qui suspectaient
kramnik qui a jamais aucun moment de sa
carrière était flagrant délit de
quelques malhonnête et que ce soit
notons au passage que la qualité des
parties n'est pas vraiment au rendez
vous il ya eu par exemple les deux
joueurs ont raté la tante 3 rappelons le
dans la seconde partie
effectivement ce qu'ils avaient aidé
s'il avait été aidé par fritz quelconque
moment de cette partie notamment ou du
matin 3 il y aura pas eu de problème il
l'aurait vu oui mais bon
les deux joueurs sont passés à côté
d'une ressource technique simple que
l'ordinateur voix en une demi-seconde
donc on enlève un petit peu les chances
que les joueurs soient aidés en tout cas
joli coup de topalov puisque en menaçant
de faire forfait
il force le forfait de chroniques et ils
marquent un point sans jouer ce qui le
ramène à deux un bon sauf que donc quand
même kramnik a posé toutes les
conditions
à noter que yumi 9 a dû rentrer
spécialement de moscou ou de russie je
sais pas où exactement où ils étaient en
réunion avec
vladimir poutine en curling ça y est
rentré spécialement en avion pour
résoudre le problème
notons stephen qu' à ce stade à ce stade
du championnat et bien on ne sait pas du
tout si le championnat va reprendre
alors voyons c'est à dire que les apps
tout joueur qui perd par forfait en
général ils n'arrivent pas à se mettre
d'accord
larbitre girl kiss and a déclaré la
défaite de l'animatronique officiel
c'est fini il ya deux ans maintenant et
normalement quand on peut en partie par
forfait de cette manière là on n'a pas
du tout envie de revenir on n'a pas
envie de le classer au stade là ont tout
le monde est sur que la liberté indique
l'arrêté jaune c'est ce qu'on a un
sentiment clash alors on va voir des
photos tout de suite ici on voit une
photo ici de en fait des écrans contrôle
ou à gauche on aperçoit la loge de
chroniques on voit ici est en fait ici
c'est carsten une stèle seller le
manager de trani comme généralement ici
donc on voit un policier qui apparemment
il un détecteur de métaux et de l'été
quentin affectés soit le samedi ne
serait en rien à un qui va les toilettes
c'est d'être kramnik et la très
probablement larbitre et à droite on
voit la loge de topalov qui lui le banc
des nominés par contre n'est pas
respectée on voit bien
alors notez quand même que tous parlent
et le championnat de file d'un ter qui
les choquent nombre de la fidh votre pas
neuf et six lieux d'un alley-oop
d'ailleurs qui disputait le reste aussi
voilà donc on va passer on va voir une
photo suivante ici topalov en train
d'inspecter des toilettes parce que
c'est les siennes c'est donc ravi qu'on
n'en sait rien on fait un vrai assez
typiquement c'est vraiment celle à faire
des toilettes on peut appeler ça le pôle
et de gate
oui j'ai vu ça quelque part sur internet
cette affaire prend des proportions
assez énorme
c'est exact mais parce qu'on n'a jamais
vu une histoire pareille voilà tout
simplement du jamais vu ici on va avoir
en fait une ici une troisième photo
alors là c'est le fameux makropoulos
alors je crois que tu avais fait
référence à un personnage de tintin des
bandes dessinées de tintin
oui non c'est parce qu'il a un nom pas
possible la stat full aux as le dépenser
makropoulos et un effectivement
quelqu'un qui est pas très apprécié par
les par les joueurs d'échecs du maire
général tout simplement parce qu'il fait
des des magouilles des complots des des
choses louches et bizarre il est
toujours dans les mauvais coups il ya de
l'argent un peu curieux qui arrive on ne
sait pas trop pourquoi c'est lui qui est
censé être là le portefeuille des
dominos quand il s'agit d'acheter les
élections pour les votes aux olympiades
on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de choses là
dessus ouais donc notre opulence a une
réputation très très sulfureuse qui est
à mon avis fondée maintenant
effectivement le mettre à la tête de
cette commission d'appel du championnat
du monde ne ressemble pas c'est un gag
mais peut-être le kramnik aurait pas dû
accepter ou sinon voilà exactement alors
c'est peut-être une fois tacite kramnik
on n'est pas autant plus qu il a épaulé
dans sa tâche par zora basse marc gilly
qui lui aussi est quand même un sacré
numéro en terme de corruption et de mélo
ne prononcera pas quand même on sait pas
ça n'engage pas dû tenir toujours
déconnectés les seconds à vide voilà il
ya toujours une suspicion d'innocence
quand les suspicions dinosaures mais
c'est vrai que ça fait quand même des
années que ces gugusses là nous fournir
des cours des détours de pendu et qu'on
est bon mais c'est pas le sipal promise
pas gagné alors à noter que cette
commission d'appel a encore une photo où
on voit encore ici makropoulos en train
de s'adresser à cramique il a l'air de
lui dire bon coup tu fais ce qu'on te
dit et tu retournes jouer à ta place
mais il n'a pas l'air d'accord l'année
mercredi qu est
cette commission d'appel a dû
démissionner voilà donc alors c'est
quand même fantastique puisque cette
commission d'appel a démissionné a été
remplacée par une nouvelle commission
d'appel dans laquelle il ya boris cool
kids notamment le le coup tine part d'un
quotidien président de la fédération
européenne rohs pénalité shell
une chronique a donné son accord
d'ailleurs pour cette nouvelle
commission
donc c'est quand même fantastique parce
que cette commission était désavoué a dû
démissionner que illumine of a rendu ses
droits chronique qui maintenant les
toilettes sont de nouveau ouvertes mais
le poids est toujours accordée à tempe
alors ce qui est n'importe quoi j'ai des
recettes il ya forcément quelque part là
la fidh et qui a fait forcément une
erreur ça peut passer pas compatibles on
peut pas d'un côté désavouer une
commission d'appel l'a remplacé redonné
les devants droit cramique est accordée
le point nos tongs pour l'histoire
stephen que donc la partie si ces lieux
puisque c'est la partie qu'on commencera
donc que vladimir kramnik est revenu il
a accepté de jouer donc soit la soul et
sous le nom le sens qu'a donnée numinnov
à la reprise du match c'était quand même
que les joueurs j'aurais pas que pour
eux il jouait aussi pour les millions de
fans d'échec ce en quoi il a raison je
pense que tout le monde avait remis que
le match continue toute façon mais qu'à
un moment donné c'est vrai que c'est
tout à fait scandaleux que chronique
soit ainsi mené au score alors la partie
du samedi a été repoussée mais pas mené
au score on était remonté et remonter
ouais ouais il est remonté par un point
est forfait à noter que le samedi donc
la partie 6 a pas eu lieu le samedi a
été reporté au dimanche a encore été
reporté le dimanche est finalement et
lebel a eu lieu le lundi
et là on est on est lundi à la fin de
cette sixième partie que maintenant on
va pouvoir voir donc en fait non kramnik
cette fois reviennent alors à noter
c'est incroyable une décision de
chroniques tout à fait spectaculaire qui
acceptent de rejouer de continuer le
match en ayant perdu deux partenaires
français c'est pratiquement du jamais vu
là surtout en plus une partie avec les
blancs où il avait des blancs donc c'est
non c'est très curieux karpov a déclaré
qu'il aurait jamais j'aurais repris le
match s'est effectivement ce qui est
tout à fait acceptable et la lumière
camille qui fait sa déclaration amusante
quand même enfin c'est plutôt rigolo je
trouve
il dit oui je j'accepte de continuer le
match mais je me réserve toutes les
options pour rediscuter du résultat de
cette partie de la partie qu'il a perdu
par forfait
ce qui n'est pas très crédible quand on
sait que s'il accepte de continuer match
c'est qu'il accepte là c'était la partie
tout simplement
donc voilà sixième partie 6e partie donc
alors qu'aux nôtres cramique a perdu
cette partie cette cinquième partie avec
les blancs faut quand même parler de ça
il a perdu cette cinquième partie riz
blanc ça veut dire qu'il a joué la
quatrième avec les noirs qui va donc la
jouer la sixième avec les noirs et quand
on arrive à la mi match
c'est ça on arrive à l'alevinage
salaunes à chengdu ce parti à la ville
ont décidé pour changer un peu les
règles des habitués aux championnats du
monde car amy match on avait inversé le
sens des couleurs ce qui fait que la
mi-match topal havas du coup reprendre
dix on est le leadership blanc ce qui
fait qu'il va jouer aussi la septième
partie avec les noirs donc il va jouer
trois parties de suite avec les noirs on
l'a dit marc raby c'est du jamais vu là
aussi dans l'histoire des championnats
du monde
oui effectivement c'est un nouveau
règlement que je comprends pas très bien
qui est de vouloir inverser les couleurs
pour la deuxième partie c'est un peu
bizarre on peut faire deux matches en
fait ouais c'est cette image féministe
est aussi parti mais alors que mon
compte le nombre de points brut donc
enfin c'est très bizarre
et effectivement la commune partie par
forfait ça fait 7
l'aberration enfin sa technique cette
aberration technique exactement trois
parties de suite avec topalov blanc vert
chronique noir alors voyons maintenant
cette sixième partie donc alors selon la
fidh et alors là aussi il faudra du coup
tenir les le compte selon la fidh et
kramnik mène 3 à 2 et selon camille qui
mène 3 1
sa beauté parce que ce point par forfait
et évidemment fera en cas d'égalité en
fin de match va faire va faire l'objet
de se parler de lui et huawei je crois
que l'histoire est loin d'être finie et
que kramnik a annoncé qu'il allait
suivre l'action en justice
donc quel que soit le résultat
d'ailleurs je pense qu'il aura raison de
le faire si on veut que la fidh évolue
il faut aussi il faut aussi mettre en
place les actions qui permettront de la
faire évoluer alors voilà septième
partie topalov donc enclenché deux
parties avec les blancs en jouant le
coût des cartes dont classique reconnaît
ce match s'en sortira pas du coût des
quatre oui apparemment les deux joueurs
ont décidé de jouer le tour dames
vestine topalov à des très bons
résultats avec des cats est un des co
qui va me sied mieux donc logiquement il
a choisi des quatre pour trouver match a
priori et vladimir kramnik pas mieux
alors donc des cinq classiques pour
l'instant on sort pas des coûts
habituels c4 donc c'est 6 toujours la
fameuse variante slave voilà donc j'ai
appris ça donc ça avec laurent précigné
autant qu'une expliqué quelques astuces
sur les dernières parties cette fameuse
défense czeslaw technique
pas facile a pas facile à jouer des deux
côtés quand même c'est solide quoi bah
c'est une des grandes ouvertures des
chèques voilà il n'y a pas grand chose à
déclarer deux spéciales les noirs ciel
au centre jeu
sur casse blanche c'est une grande
ouverture à la mode donc effectivement
c'est technique c'est technique c'est
compliqué parce qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de théories et puis que tout le
monde tout ça en ce moment
donc effectivement une ouverture du
remix de fans technique donc on défend
très bien des cinq et on se laisse la
possibilité de sortir ce fou plutôt de
le bloquer tout de suite avec le 6 alors
la suite
carl f 3 kal el 6/4 lycée 3 et comprend
c4 donc on a donc fait une authentique
slavin puisque donc on le rappelle une
fois de plus dans cette version il ya un
choix très critique pour les noirs et
plusieurs coups il ya aussi ce qui est
une possibilité qui donne de la semi
slave à six qui donne la fameuse la
veille cassis et le coût des princes et
4 qui est le coût de la slave
authentique original telle qu'elle a été
conçue au départ tel cas étaient
conscients des lundis d'été procès car
c'est à dire que maintenant on a pris 1
6 4 en appuyant ses six dont on prépare
à l'avancé des cinq pour soutenir
l'option c4 donc c'est ça l'idée au
départ de l'esclave cette mode à ses
pieds en france et 4 voilà c'est fait sa
force les blancs à jouer à 4 puisque
sinon les noirs rageot des cinq cd
sacrifice de pions qui sont assez
douteux pour les banques
ça marche pas très bien donc pour forcer
les blancs joie car maintenant on
s'aperçoit que la caisse bay 4-2 des
faibles donc c'est une belle case pour
le développement des dégâts alors voilà
casey mois soit le fou de temps en temps
il ya certainement dix sept cavaliers
qui y va donc les nous les noirs ont
pris cette classe b 4 est en revanche
les blancs et de les hanter le sens
puisqu'on voit dix ans maintenant les
options semblent comptés ans elle entre
en scène nous voilà c'est un débat un
débat d'idées débat d'idées très bien
alors donc là aussi l'idée de cet islam
sait maintenant après fou et l5
évidemment quand on jouera aussi c'est
dire que le fou est pas derrière ces
tiens y'a pas coincé donc c'est une les
possibilités comme ça de développer le
foot 5e empêche évidemment les plans de
jouer eux deux 80 ce qui est très
important
contrôle très bien évidemment la case 4
avec le fou et lecavalier voilà donc
empêchant empêcher la libération
centrale qui serait très bien pour les
blancs et la plage où son coup
maintenant qu'ils
et là on est pas on ne sent pas encore
de nouveautés je pense pas c'est plus
c'est le groupe principal non mais par
rapport à ce qui a été jouée sur les
parties précédentes
oui il avait joué que trois là il avait
joué voilà il avait joué trois pour
reprendre tout de suite c'est ça voilà
pour reprendre toutes les îles
il a une très bonne position c'est la
partie où il était gagnant assez
facilement hélas pas fou de rage mais sa
baisse quel taux pas l'ofii zhu qui
avait dit aux cinq cavaliers le sait le
grand coup le camp principal dans sa
cavale est bien placé au centre
profitant du fait qu'on est protégé et
puis bon ça va contrôler des cases
intéressant donc ici maintenant on peut
mentionner la variante
qui est à la mob qui est donc allée b 17
calais b 17 plaqués france et 4 à
prendre le pion et là je crois que
le principal en relâchement j'ai un
petit trou de mémoire à cette position
il ya une grande blanche croit que ces
dames c'est cette en préparant de 5 kw
adams et 7 et ensuite pour préparer 1,5
et après j'ai 3 il ya des parties très
très compliqué s'asseoir dans tous les
sens
j'ai donc c'est une possibilité mais
mais les joueurs ne rentre pas là dedans
puisque l'art kramnik a choisi le cou
aux six plus calme c'est pas que c'est
plus calme c'est que c'est l'ancien
principal c'est que s'il y avait des
centaines de parties avec 2,6 notamment
des partis mercredi avec les blancs on à
face est moins agressif puisque l'idée
avec 1,5 c'est quand même très agressif
alors que là aussi c'est quand même plus
calmes serge et c'est pas d'attaqué au
sein de tout de suite il veut il veut
jouer le c5 très certainement plus tard
alors que six il faut dire que c'est la
très très grandes variantes que c'est
extrêmement compliqué et que il ya un
sacrifice de pièces qui arrivent
théorique
donc on va voir on va voir on va voir
tout de suite rex 3 s'il ya beaucoup de
choses fort c'est donc la logique dans
cette situation donc ici on joue f3 pour
maintenant pousser les quatre puisque
les deux pièces adverse pour l'instant
contrôlé très bien la case le card donc
il faut arriver à percer au sein de
puisque c'est la compensation des blancs
alors c'est toute l'idée d'avoir déplacé
le cavalier aux cinq qui étaient sur la
kf3 c'est justement de pouvoir avancer
ses pions et de jouer aux quatre on
s'aperçoit que quand on a installé une
phalange de pions donc sur cases
blanches si avec et dans le foot doit
battre en retraite en v6 et les noirs se
retrouve avec un fou g6 complètement
muselé puisque il tape justement sur
cette chaîne d'options très solide nous
qui table sur le client quatre blindés
ouais et on s'aperçoit que cavalia 2 6
au passage est également muselés parce
que toutes les cases où il peut aller
son contrôle est d'accord par les blancs
donc en fait c'est une stratégie
d'enfermement
ici que fait topaloff c'est à dire
qu'ils jouent ou ont joué aux quatre
contre les deux pièces faut il
s'inquiéter ça c'est tout à fait normal
maintenant le coût principal dans cette
position et où il ya eu énormément de
parti un nombre colossal de partie c'est
le souper 4 on va vous montrer la
variante sans entrer dans les détails
parce qu'elle est extrêmement compliqué
le 4 est là il sacrifice de biasi langue
dans la pièce où chrome 4 comprend pions
pour profiter du cloud âge qu'elle va
dire on néanmoins récupéré deux pions
d'opioïdes et en menacent de prendre
encore le cavalier maintenant le pousser
sous des deux et on peut prendre des
cartes d'un producteur en 2004 ça fait
déjà trois pions ça fait trois pions
pour la pièce donc on peut on peut
supposer que c'est déjà intéressant de
calculer ce à quoi
c'est à dire que en fait on va finir par
trois pions pour la pièce du jeu dans
tous les sens beaucoup beaucoup de
partis devaient tenir chronique avec les
blancs qui a joué ça notamment alors il
ya plus de dix ans je pense dans son
match contre joué de l'hôte et hakam
match qui date un petit peu et qu'ils
gagnaient quel blanc assez facilement
donc voila apres f3 le coût principal
était fou les quatre pendant très
longtemps et on s'est aperçu la pratique
reste la pratique moderne a montré que
les blancs avec leur pièce de plus
arrivent à transformer l'avantagé
d'accord donc c'est comme ça serait
davantage de langue donc c'est pour ça
que cramique des vies sans doute de sept
grandes variantes pour jouer à notre
course et 5
oui c'est simple qui est un coût quasi
oubliée donc logiquement aussi dans le
quotidien cologie protégé par le faux
évidemment et ce qu'ils ont fait
pression sur le centre profitant du pion
aussi qu' étant réussissent déjà en
pêchant notamment la poussée des 5
donc c'est le pion des quatre étant
immobilisé c'est peut-être ça peut être
le bon moment pour l'échangé donc c'est
un coup logique à ta mossad
alors je ne dirais pas que c'est un peu
logique stéphane parce que il ya un
énorme problème à jouer ces 5
alors on perd du temps exactement encore
du temps déjà je vois c'est si c'est
maintenant que ces seuils mais d'un
autre côté ça affaiblit cette diagonale
mais comme quand on a joué à quatre
c'est moins grave y'a plus qu'à pas de
la dame qui peut venir facilement le fou
est loin de venir en b5 donc non pas du
tout il n'est pas très loin de stephen
hayes bourgeois il faut le voir c'est
qu'on joue encore à croupion que notre
roi est loin d'être protégés on est
encore en lui leurs ouailles pas encore
pas encore fait le rock mais c'est super
le fou comme tu l'as dit le fouquet's
blanche née ne peut plus revenir ne vous
pourrez venir défendre les casses gauche
oui c'est le souci et en même temps on
n'a pas évité de 4 voilà c'est ça ma nes
ou six avec la libération de ce fou
évidemment un coût qui est typique de
vladimir kramnik c'est à dire vers canet
qui dit je n'ai pas de faiblesse la
structure de pion est correct on a la
même structure de pions j'ai pas trop de
désavantage de développement donc
l'ajout cette position et puis je pense
que je vais l'accrocher je vais faire
mais je vais faire passer l'activité
supérieur des pièces blanches et puis ça
valait d'ailleurs c'est le coût que
choisit topalov agressif mais c'est
compliqué hein tout de suite parce qu'il
ya un 4 kathak le fou les noirs pourrait
éventuellement choisir de répliquer par
pions 30 des quatre avec ici on le voit
eh bien tu attaques m'en fous mais
j'attaque car ici il y aurait trop de
longs stéphane comme sion pour 9,5 alors
il y aurait pu on prend un excellent
parce que scipion grands cavaliers qui
empruntent cavaliers d'un micro d'un
échec d'apprendre à mes chèques croître
on apprend qu'elle est problème c' est
la fourchette
voilà donc c'est pas possible tac et on
va prendre la tour donc ici par exemple
3,8 et cavaliers voilà ici on voit mal
effectivement probablement les noirs
vont reprendre ce qu'avait dit à chaud
suite
par la suite ce qui les mettra sur sa
faim de qualité grâce aux gens qui
étaient de qualité ici la dernière
mouture contre une classe 12h06 est
toujours là sera en plus face à une
pièce mineurs le font par exemple où le
cavalier donc ça sera toujours un
avantage
donc on revient sur la partie donc cette
possibilité n'existe pas donc finalement
on peut que reculer que vous exactement
mais c'est ce qu'a fait crâne rouge et
c6 maintenant fouet trois logiques
logique développement comprend
maintenant deux des quatre qui devenait
maintenant
les menaces voilà donc ici les banques
ont une position nettement menaçant plus
de champions français 5
c'est donc là on menace puisque un peu
le plan ses cadres à tomber par le fou
là on a rendu le plus
voyons ici que les blancs ont sorti une
pièce de plus que les noirs on puisse
les dents sorties trois pièces contre
2,3 que les pièces noirs sont enfermés
complètement
bref si cg65 puisque enfermé par cette
phalange de pions avec 3,4 donc ici
davantage très très logiquement devrait
être du côté blanche un avantage
considérable en tout cas à la vue de
tous et de tous ces critères un petit
avance de développement pièce noire
enfermé l'option c4 qui va être
récupérée par le fouet les cases
blanches faible autour de roanne -
salaire de faire beaucoup on va voir que
bladimir kramnik évidemment connais bien
cette position comme des sales affaires
du bjp un crachat à dire chez lui et va
jouer des coups maintenance d'une
précision assez diabolique et avec un
sang-froid monumentales on va voir
comment il arrive à calmer le jeu ici
alors il choisit pu reprendre des 4 il
faut reprendre alors du fou ou de la
dame dont un prix non il faut développer
ces pièces c'est ça voilà moi je préfère
naturellement la reprise de la dame
parce que donc été jouée par topaloff
tout simplement parce que ça ou la
reprise du fouet quand même semble aussi
une alternative possible de résilier
quelque chose de similaire garder les
dames pourront éventuellement l'attaqué
et c'est bon d'être ne pose pas de
problème particulier reprendre de la
dame est préférable parce que justement
on laisse une tournée sur la colonne des
on échange les dames on voit que la dame
noire des fonds un peu le roi noir aussi
donc en fait d'un prend des quatre noms
le coup logique donc ça a été jouée
d'appréhender 4 et la chronique et dans
saute sur l'occasion pour échanger les
dames et à prix fous prend les quatre
choisi de terminer son développement
quasiment alors non il appellerait ça
stéphane il a joué le nôtre qui avaient
parié un très très haut rhinois qui est
un détail extrêmement et parfums suis
trompé de voie là je suis trompé de
cavaliers
carly f17 mais c'est pas la même chose
kalif 17 alors pourquoi
eh bien à cela plusieurs raisons par
ailleurs il a logiquement explique nous
l'idée est d'aller échanger déjà échangé
ce qu'ils avaient dit là qui ne
supportent pas donc il faut les changer
tout simplement on peut voir que si on
joue comme fo s'était petit rock la
position de devenir assez durs à jouer
rapidement d'autant plus que probable
sur fois celle qu'il ya peut-être des
petits câbles les médecins qui traînent
des choses comme ça on veut changer ce
cavalier qui est trop fort maintenant
donc on va jouer qu'il va dire un camion
17 si on joue soit cavaliers là les
kenyans bébé en 17
on va s'apercevoir qu'il va y avoir un
problème dans cette pression donc
simplement par exemple qui avait dépensé
4 ici à nous de jouer mais qu'est-ce
comment on va sortir nos pièces
maintenant c'est sa toute la question
par exemple d'après fouet cette wii donc
déjà il ya des possibilités techniques à
base de simples keolis qui se retrouve
mal placé je pense que même si ici
topalov jude époux simple par exemple
qu'à valider cinq qui est intéressant
voire le avancer les pions à 5 pour
mettre la pression sur pion à cette
baignoire vous manquez de coûts ils
arrêtent le sortir leur caisse comme ça
alors que nous allons voir que dans la
partie
rien à voir rafa qui veut libérer son
cavalier de l'emprise des perdants à des
plans blancs après que alliage 17 et
bien le plan maintenant pour kramix et
f6 sfef 7e 5 qui égalise
c'était il est très important de libérer
de faire place cette pièce en fait
exactement il remplace sa pièce ils
voient les reliefs s'il est condamné à
être passif
autre chose importante si tu es fan
c'est que sur canal et france les quatre
maintenant
donc comme on l'a vu avant c'était tout
à fait possible le cavalier bien dans
ces sites
voilà ce qui est plus actif issu un
sacré écart ont été radiés celle ci est
bien placé qui tiennent toutes les cases
c'est un bourg plus fort c'est plus fort
sacha se fout des quatre essais très
importante du temps on quand on revient
maintenant dans cette position là et
bien si on réfléchit un petit peu on
voit qu'il ya pas photo c'est ce qui
avait déjà qui doit venir ici pour
perdre votre avis et pour garder
l'option qu'a bicis d'accord dont le
en somme au dos pour résumer on veut
liquider ce caillou 5 on veut donc
mettre à quai à lyon 17
et quand on choisit on s'aperçoit que
naturellement c'est le cavalier f qui
doit y aller très bien kalev 17 là car
il y prend cavaliers donc là c'est donc
c'est logique reprise est maintenant
foot en ckd logique là on sort sa
dernière pièce tout en prenant le fameux
pion qui nous manquait depuis tout à
l'heure
donc c'est ce pion en fait qu'en général
on n'arrive pas à gagner avec les a
regardés avec les noirs de toute façon
voilà c'est fait le développement on
peut dire est quasi terminée pour les
blancs maintenant les blancs de choix
petit roth peut-être même grand rock
voire même droit de plein de
possibilités pour le roi il ne te fout
des quatre exerce une petite pression
désagréables sur toulon g7
oui donc ça immobilise le fou et en même
temps il ya des possibilités de fou b5
ou cavaliers b5 des invasions sur les
sur ces cases cavaliers ici le cavalier
ou fou et c'est pourquoi cramique joue à
six voilà tout simplement d'abord en
plus ça enlève
ici ce fou qui table un oeil sur a7 donc
ces pratiques parce que la tour va
pouvoir rencontrer en jeu et
éventuellement est aussi évidemment ça
contrôle dans cette case d'évasion pour
un fou ou pour un cavalier et là mettant
effectivement donc là topalov fauzy
droit 2 plutôt que de faire en rock
alors on fait souvent ça quand on estime
qu'entre dès qu'on est proche de la
finale est là on est en finale on est en
finale même on peut dire puisque les
dames soient échangés mais enfin c'est
pas vraiment une finale finale quoi il
ya encore beaucoup de pièces alors le
mais le roi on va estimer que la le
topalov estime que son roi sera safe en
deux un tranquille et ils estiment
qu'ils sera il vaudra mieux que le roi
soit plus proche du centre en deux que
en juin où il aurait fallu rejouer des
coûts en plus pour aller vers le centre
ce qui peut arriver si on arrive dans
une finale dans cette logique parce que
l'on en croit deux le snit balough
anticipe que les échanges de tours vont
arriver il ya deux colonnes ouverte
pourront s'échanger colonne ouverte ici
cette colonne et cette colonne là donc
ils anticipent pour les échanges de
tours donc logiquement il préfère que
son rôle soit bien placée au centre on
voit que le roi eu deux ne risque
absolument rien pour le moment il peut
pas être mis en échec n'a aucune pièce
noire et c'est une situation qui risque
de durer dont 3,2 évidemment beaucoup de
logique que l'ast donc tour j'ai vite
alors logique mais pas facile à trouver
quand même hein c'est pas logique un peu
quand même si parce qu'on protège le
pion pour sortir le fou voilà on veut
sentir ce fou c'est l'idée de crâne dit
qu'il veut sortir se font par exemple en
d4 pour échanger et peut-être avec un
cavalier je ne sais pas où en 6 5 pour
ses échanges avec le fou donc ils
protègent de qui ont baissé moi je
dirais plutôt que je sais ce que ça
coûte il fait peur
disons oui ça fait peur c sa la pa si ça
a l'air évidemment ces passifs à la
tourbe on allait pas superbe super
attaquant s quel s creek ce qui est
intéressant de noter donc on peut
revenir sur la position précédente
dans cette situation là il faut voir
donc effectivement les colonies verte
salut mais il faut voir que toujours le
plan cf6 fou et 7
mais pour le moment on a un énorme
problème c'est qu'il faut défendre
l'option de 6 parce que si on avance le
pion mais c'est bien le fou il ya un
rapport entre cette option tout à fait
donc ça c'est le problème donc chronique
ici se demande comment va se passer la
suite de la partie ils voient que
effectivement ils implantent qui est
donc tour j'ai vite fou rouge
mettons en d4 3e set des champions aux
6es après absents f6 fo sl et là ils
égalisent maintenant s'être mis donc la
douleur chronique doit avoir peur c'est
que tout le monde aura peur de jouer un
coup ko torje lite pour mona c'est fou
bécade pour menacer recettes pour 29,6
qui au final va n'a toujours rien n'est
tout à fait donc effectivement c'est
très loin ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
pour te pas l'autre et bien c'est très
difficile de trouver un plan d'options
et ça c'est les situations chroniques
est bien c'est que la taupe est l'homme
qui peut mettre septembre au centre mais
comme on va le voir ça ne donnera pas
grand chose et c'est très difficile de
trouver un plan incriptions tout
simplement parce qu'un accord si on joue
h 4 mai sprint open régional 5 ça va se
bloquer si on joue g4 et bien on
arrivera un coup trop tard au moment où
un joueur acheté à traîner your f6 donc
en fait ici il n'ya plus vraiment de
possibilités pour topalov et semblerait
que vladimir kramnik et bien tout
analysé veste et au palace n'a rien
trouvé donc probablement cette position
serait égale donc tour j'ai vite quand
même tour hd 1
on craint donc ils centralisent sa tour
l'arrêt trouver mieux
tours s'est vite d'où l'intérêt d'avoir
joué à 6 tout à l'heure le pion à sète
n'est plus en prise par le fou aussi
donc la tour peut venir en actions tout
de suite ça attaque le flou donc c'est
un développement avec gain de temps un
continent toujours puisque les blancs
doivent défendre le fou topal choisi de
jouer b3 et de protéger son fou par le
pion et là maintenant le fameux full c5
maintenant évidemment on va échanger se
fout n'y a pas eu de pollution pour les
blancs puisque
dans le saint qui se remplissent de
cavaliers donc sous faulx va être
échangé c'est sûr ça va aussi libérer la
tour c'est à dire qu'une fois après
qu'on aura échanger se fout de cases
noires on pourra mettre le roi recettes
sans crainte d'être mis en échec puisque
le fou quasiment disparu et la tour g8
va pouvoir éventuellement revenir au
centre donc là n'ont pas choisi à 5 ou
qu'ils essaient de faire une impression
dans la classe b si ça sent qu'il ya
quoi c'est logique c'est à dire que te
pas d'offres anticipe les changes des
fous de cases noires donc plus bientôt
aucun camp devront être quasiment donc
là il serait important d'avoir fixé des
pions sur des cases blanches de la
couleur de son passé exactement
on a chacun aura son fluctuat blanche
donc ce sera important pour les blancs
de mettre leurs pions sur 4 noir donc
topalov anticipe là dessus est
effectivement que tu l'as dit stéphane
lecavalier qui peut revenir sur les
thèses b6 cette case qui maintenant est
fixé donc voilà de l'idée de ce coin 5
qui est d'une logique implacable et et
en même temps un coup assez simple c'est
à dire que c'est pas positionnement
extrêmement complexe et un bon réflexe
mais les pions sur la couleur de son fou
data qui restera une fois que ces deux
fous ont été échangés le fou ici il est
bien content que de pouvoir avoir des
cibles même si tout de suite s'il peut
pas les attaquer puisque s'est défendu
mais s'il pouvait plus tard être par
exemple 4 une fois que ça a bougé tout
ça et bien il fixerait une pièce noire à
la défense du tube et cède donc cédé oui
il ya aussi des sacrifices a fait partie
éventuellement envisager des sacrifices
très éventuel retrait éventuel en ça
peut arriver on peut prendre une pièce
contre devions on aurait 2 pour passer
liés au si ça peut être des tel un signe
recettes classiques kramnik aussi se
pressent pas pour faire les échanges
parce qu'ils estiment si les bleus
richard jeu même ont cavalé sera pas mal
sur nancy 5
voilà son raisonnement sans doute
quoique même avec la tour c'est bien
peut-être pour doubler les tours aussi
bat surtout le raisonnement c'est qu'il
va jouer si c'est le 5e maintenant il va
jouer f6 et si un échange et les faux et
faux à cet effet changé dernier fou
yacht ou échanger chronique pour prévenu
exactement car il ya quatre donc là
topalov continu n'a cette fois ils
menacent cette fois de prendre avec le
cavalier ce qui serait pas la même chose
si on perdait la paire de fou et il peut
aussi enlevé son foulard
de la deûle attaque alors on a
l'impression kramnik devrait ici échange
les foules on a cette impression là mais
lorsqu on inspecte la position d'un peu
plus près on va s'apercevoir que donc
venir cramer qui a joué le coup
théâtre un nom qui finalement ne change
pas s'il ne change pas voter sa première
idée exactement
en fait c'est une sorte de contre-pied
ils sont de changement de direction mais
il attaque le pion ils attaquent futur à
cinq quitte donc la visite faiblesse
finalement et il en fait il a décidé
vladimir kramnik que maintenant que
topalov a investi du temps pour jouer à
5 et cavalli à 4 sert pour menacé
d'envahir cette classe b 6 eh bien il
n'est plus temps il faut garder les
fougasses noir maintenant c'est plus
logique et il a tout à fait raison
on peut regarder la vente souvent des
quatre points cardinaux reprend et 4 et
si ça devient un peu compliqué donc
logiquement tour à tour vient soit
centralisé oui
ici on peut envisager un coup très
simples comme toi d1 et maintenant on
s'aperçoit que il est resté avec son fou
ici que le coup et si c'est pas si
évident à jouer parce qu'il ya des
combinaisons par exemple tout reprend 17
marcherait qui a l'air de marcher qu'à
l'art du marché puisque à la fin il y
aurait un échec du careï un peu le
montrer un peu montré f6 ici pour fonder
cet échec
pourtant tous reprendront tour on
reprend et intérêts la pointe la petite
fourchette petite fourchette échec échec
au roi avec la tour leur revient ici par
exemple comprend la tour et après roy
prend brands 6 à la fin à la fin avec
une finale techniquement gagner moi
c'est gagnant est tout simple aucun
parti
et en plus parce que les pionniers en
plus les pieds ensemble sont bloqués
sont sur la mauvaise cola tout à fait
donc ça c'est le genre de choses les
variantes comme une autre qui peut
arriver si on joue au foot prend des
quatre qui permet aux blancs de
reprendre la tour de doubler rapidement
leurs pièces et en même temps d'avoir
une meilleure structure d'options donc
on vous l'a dit laconique évidemment
d'anticiper sur ce genre de possibilités
et avaient prévu de jouer tous les
quatre
il faut des quatre alors la suite voilà
cavaliers b6 donc la pop à la farine pas
le choix trop hein parce qu'en fait que
plus on est attaqué donc quand je
remplis les six qui protège champions
avec la tour et une tonne propose aussi
un échange et la chronique n'a pas non
plus le choix il ya une sorte de
fourchette entre deux pièces on
envisager les contours csn en face et on
n'a pas envie non pas en vitraux de
jouer ce genre de coups et signe c'est
vous et les changes est logique
voilà vous prend il faut voir que
vesselin topalov a perdu beaucoup de
temps parce qu'on voit que le trajet du
qualifié trois fois rien bessines
c'était non oui et qu'il n'a fallu qu'un
seul couac roddick pour l'échangé donc
en fait en fourrière et si demain vous
l'a dit bertrand monique récupère son
handicap
nathan aux deux temps sur la pendule
mais d'autant sur l'échiquier en tant en
termes de coûts de développement et que
ici maintenant effectivement il arrive à
jouer le coup et 6 donc maintenant il
joue f6 et là ça y est ils assemblent
petit plan 5 et engagement il faut
laisser tomber changer ce fou faudra
quand même faire attention pénétration
de la tour sur la 7e donc on me
regardait la suite tour des 3 et là tout
de suite tour66 d'abord dans un premier
temps effet kramnik alors peut-être
qu'il veut échanger les tours en cas de
doublement ils veulent changer du tout
mais c'est exactement ça donc si en fait
ils évitent ces petits levitz et qui par
la menace qu'ils étaient quand même 2 e
tour est-ce qu'on peut pas renier en dix
huit mois la cause du fou donc voila
mais par contre on peut venir des 6 et
s'il arrive à échanger une tour s'est de
suite beaucoup moins dangereux puisque
une pénétration 17 n'est plus possible
donc ici topalov je choisis le coup h
quatre mois il faut dire que la position
inchangée de dévaluation ici maintenant
les noirs ne risque absolument rien dans
cette situation c'est plutôt les blancs
qui doivent faire attention parce que
justement le coeur a5 risque d'être fait
de temps en temps ces options peuvent
être fait pour restaurer n'est pas
défendu et il est sous pression du fou
donc ça oblige le foot mais si ça reste
ayant b6 nous la tour ici donc il faut
en tout cas laisser une pièce à la
défense du pian donc c'est toujours un
peu passif s'il ya plus vraiment quand
même pour venir tanguay qui a le danger
c'est 8 tracts il alors là je pense que
l'idée aussi bon d'avoir un là pour être
beaucoup mieux si wynants quand les 8 ou
les pas du tout active et on peut
envisager d'échanger des
détour sur la case des 6 et ensuite
remettre une tour ans et 6 pour revenir
éventuellement sur la casse des six
aussi la possibilité puis bon ça
l'atout russie où il va vouloir
s'activent évidemment pourra pas passer
puisque ce fou contrôler ici par le pion
contrôle très bien empêche toute
pénétration sur la commune c'est mais
cette case c6 c7 casse d'ici sont les
casques les qui permettent de provoquer
des échanges d'ici g4 de topalov menaces
sans doute h5 sait ce qu'il veut faire
sans doute et créer un peu la pression
sur le sur la chaîne de pion à berck où
il essaie surtout de gagner du terrain
c'est de gagner du terrain de l'espace
c'est ça ils sont à gagner de l'espace
on est sur la quatrième ils voient que
le plus grand chose à tirer de la
colonne des à cause de tour des six qui
neutralisera tout donc ici c'est qu'elle
plus grand-chose topalov mais il joue
quelques coups il est il expliqué c'est
peut être moins bien tout simplement
parce qu'il continue à jouer fous ces
cinq du cratère est un arriviste
jeunesse et leur jeu menace fou prend
puis on prend un tour en gagne un pion
exhaler topalov répond calmement par
tour a des seins menace peut venir sur
la 7e oui il faut il faut noter que s'il
n'avait pas joué tour a des seins mais
je prends fou alors s'il allait jouer le
fou prend fonds à la loupe à la tour
prends tout reprend et s'ils auraient eu
des petits problèmes pour les blancs ça
commence à se
se préciser parce que le pion à 5 on
peut plus vraiment le défendre ce pion
difficilement défendable évidemment si
on essayait de protéger sa me voyais un
problème du fou et il peut n'y a pas de
casse ou foule et en plus ce même hargne
est temps qu'il parte ça laisserait une
pénétration ou deux tours sur la colonne
c est ici il ya des plans maintenant
pour pour les noirs
donc c'est la 6e fois de 7 et celui de
5,7 fait il ya moins de points 8
celui de h5 ou h5 tout de suite ou huit
d'une manière générale les tournois sont
plus actifs que les tours blanches tout
simplement avec un léger avantage pour
les attaques le pion à 5
voilà voilà le problème très bien alors
on va regarder la suite on va voir
comment ça se simplifie donc il n'a pas
joué naturellement fut grand fou il et
je vais tout raté un jouet tour adn
d'abord mali et la foux prendre fou
maintenant pour kramnik to reflect
logique avant de reprendre puisque on
pénètre sur la 7ème donc ça c'est quand
même de sa part est dangereux et on va
voir que ça l'est pas tant que ça il a
tout calculé crâne y croit et fuit
protection de cette normale et a pris
apprend b6 tout reprend mais si on
protège de pions 17 et on a pris un pion
donc là on peut dire même que le bon
mais on peut dire que cette tour quand
même et quand même menaçante mais on
peut pas doubler les tours sur la 7ème
ses acceptions n'a pas de cas ni ici
surtout ce qui me l'a annoncé que la
baignoire autant plus quand même ea
vient de plus voilà c'est ça mais il ya
quand même cet or en septième qui est
quand même une vraie menace
77e et il ya cet avantage des espaces
aussi à droite qui est pas négligeable
là je pense pas qu'on puisse vraiment
traiter cette question avec des
généralités c'était frais parce qu'on
menace h5 eloi h5 fouilles cette célèbre
phone 7 mais on peut apprécier de casser
la structure le 8
elle a évidemment faux et 8 menace la
tour sera obligée de battre en retraite
ça c'est évidemment la promenade mais le
pion aussi ce sera un peu faible donc
non bbc simplement
il faut dire que vesselin topalov a vu
un coût pour les montres qui récupère le
pion voilà ça c'est certain
donc c'est important c'est le coutour de
six attaques la cour est maintenant le
pion aux 6 et attaquer aussi donc la
chronique on va voir simplifie voile est
obligatoire pour tout reprend le bureau
sis maintenant et toujours attaquer et
la chronique choisi deux d'en profiter
pour échanger les tours facilement avec
tours 6
voilà maintenant si tu prend 1,6 à visa
pour j'échange évidemment alors pardon
si tu prends en eux si si si ça serait
une faute
évidemment là il y aurait davantage noir
puisque après tout reprendre pour fou
prend bien les noirs auraient le fameux
pions passé lointain est là ça serait
beaucoup plus lorsque ça s'était fait
virer fou et 7 le réfutent cette donnée
tout de suite la fois cette foi et cette
voie là regardez plus pions passé voilà
l'option passé douaniers qui est donc
qui gagne et marche aussi en finale de
fou mais qui m'a particulièrement bien
au final d'options ici damant le pion
est attaquée non mélaniques on peut
aussi jouer fou s'est vite voilà fou
s'est vite on on s'est vus on aura
comprend 30 17
et quand même à 5 avec menace à 4 à 3 à
2 et on va pas trop comment paris ça
ramène à moins d' amener le roi et la sq
à la halle aux grains noirs à toute
liberté d'aller prendre ses pions ouais
dans ce genre de pression et les belles
chances de gain pour l'état une grande
chance doit être très grandes chances d
y est tout à fait donc tout reprend ses
six pour topalov pour éviter un don
qu'il faut pas prendre évidemment
réussissent va permettre ces finales
tourcoing faut d'abord échangé les tours
logique
ensuite on prend 7 6 qui on prend 6 am
ceci gestes techniques de topalov il
joue pas fou pour 1,6 tout de suite
parce qu'ils auraient du coup c'est
simple on prend 1,6 ou faut prendre si
ce nom il jouait très bien joué lorsque
d'immobilisation de la mort des quatre
est jolie il met son pion sur noir donc
illuminer mobilise les purins d'air sur
blanc c'est toujours mieux et au coup
d'après il à prendre soin aussi ce soit
à 6,5 de kram nique et après il faudra
six propositions nul même les blancs un
tout petit avantage des champions c'est
si ce qui semble armé c'est qu'une toute
petite faiblesse donc ici
tous les noirs amène le roux indécis
selon madame leroy rentrer des six
élections étant sur noir on n'a pas n'a
pas d'autres faiblesses c'est quasi
impossible de passer
voilà donc ici c'est une nulle des nuls
y'a plus rien à en tirer de cette
mythique donc nulle et après tout cet
épisode des toilettes et de cette
fameuse commission d'appel donc radical
a été déstabilisée surtout on lui a volé
un point on peut dire ça je comprends
tout le monde est d'accord sur tous les
forums internet où les grands sites
internet pour dire que le point lui a
été volée pas une commission d'appel qui
n'est pas par qui est partial
les roses véreuses vous faites au cou
tout cas un fonds qui n'est pas partial
quoi qui a désintégré y compris finances
il puisque ils sont payés en fait part
par la fim pour office et pour officier
oui mon niveau fils officiers officiers
n'ont qu'un seul bon il ya des
personnages sauf qu'elle reviendra dans
les prochaines émissions dont on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé encore c'est silvio
danilov le manager de topalov qui est un
personnage très particulier et c'est lui
qui à l'origine fait un peu de tout
cette histoire et de tout ce qui s'est
passé là faire des toilettes c'est un
peu l'idée de silvio danilov à vietri
quitte à man le manager de topalov
depuis vraiment plusieurs années c'est
lui qui l'a coaché depuis le début on
reviendra sur ce personnage quand même
assez facile tout à fait donc résultat
après cette sixième partie et ainsi on
considère c'est la sixième partie que la
cinquième a été acquise par topalov par
forfait et bien c'est 3.5 pour kramnik
face contre 2,5 à topalov rendez vous
pour la septième partie si elle a lieu
s'ils veulent
bon